como Pong, Snake y Tetris.
Se imaginarán la enorme alegría de jugar
con un Tetris que uno mismo escribió en JACK
y luego compiló en lenguaje máquina en un compilador
que también escribió, y luego ver el resultado
ejecutando en una máquina que uno construyó
partiendo de nada más que unos miles de compuertas NAND.
Es un triunfo personal enorme partir de principios
fundamentales para llegar a un sistema extremadamente complejo
y útil.
Noam y yo trabajamos cinco años para facilitar
este ascenso y crear las herramientas y la infraestructura
para que los estudiantes construyan esto en un semestre.
Y este es el gran equipo que nos ayudó a realizarlo.
El truco consistió en descomponer la construcción
en muchos módulos independientes,
que pudiesen especificarse de forma individual,
y construirse y probarse de manera aislada del resto del proyecto.
Desde el primer día, Noam y yo decidimos poner
a disposición estos bloques libremente como código abierto
en la Web.
Dejamos especificaciones de chips, APIs, especificaciones
del proyecto, simuladores de hardware, emuladores de CPU,
pilas de cientos de diapositivas, conferencias...
dejamos todo eso en la Web
e invitamos al mundo a venir
y tomar lo que necesitara
y hacer lo que quisiera con esto.
Y entonces ocurrió algo fascinante.
El mundo vino.
Y, en poco tiempo, miles de personas
estaban construyendo nuestra máquina.
Así, NAND2Tetris fue uno de los primeros
cursos web abiertos y masivos,
aunque hace siete años no teníamos ni idea de que
eso en inglés se llamaba MOOC.
Sólo notábamos cómo se desprendían cursos
autoorganizados espontáneamente
a partir de nuestros materiales.
Por ejemplo, Pramode C.E.,
un ingeniero de Kerala, India,
ha organizado grupos de autodidactas
que construyen nuestra máquina bajo su buena dirección.
Y Parag Shah, otro ingeniero, de Mumbai,
desagregó nuestros proyectos en partes
más pequeñas y manejables que ahora ofrece
en su programa aficionado de ciencias de la computación.
Las personas atraídas por estos cursos
por lo general tienen mentalidad de 'hacker'.
Quieren saber cómo funcionan las cosas,
y quieren hacerlo en grupos,
como este club de hackers en Washington, DC,
que usa nuestros materiales en cursos comunitarios.
Y como estos materiales están ampliamente disponibles
y son de código abierto, las personas pueden
cambiar el rumbo en direcciones imprevistas.
Por ejemplo, Yu Fangmin, de Guangzhou,
ha usado la tecnología FPGA
para construir nuestra computadora y mostrarle a otros cómo hacer lo mismo
mediante un video y Ben Craddock desarrolló
un videojuego muy bonito
en nuestra arquitectura de CPU, un laberinto 3D
bastante complejo desarrollado por Ben
con el simulador Minecraft 3D.
La comunidad de Minecraft se volvió loca con este proyecto
y Ben se convirtió en una celebridad mediática.
Y, en efecto, para algunas personas
emprender esta peregrinación del NAND2Tetris, si se quiere,
se ha convertido en una experiencia que les cambió la vida.
Por ejemplo, Dan Rounds, músico y especialista
en matemática de East Lansing, Michigan.
Hace pocas semanas, Dan publicó un mensaje victorioso
en nuestro sitio, y me gustaría leérselo.
Esto es lo que dijo Dan:
"Hice el curso porque entender la computación es tan importante
para mí como la alfabetización y la aritmética,
y lo logré. Nunca antes había trabajado tan arduamente en algo,
nunca antes enfrenté semejante desafío.
Pero sabiendo como ahora sé de lo que soy capaz,
sin duda lo volvería a hacer.
Para quien esté considerando hacer NAND2Tetris,
es un viaje difícil, pero te cambiará significativamente".
Dan demostró que muchos autodidactas
toman este curso desconectados, a su propio ritmo,
por iniciativa propia, y es muy sorprendente porque
a estas personas no podría importarles menos
las calificaciones.
Lo hacen motivados por una sola cosa.
Sienten una enorme pasión por aprender.
Y con eso en mente,
me gustaría decir unas palabras sobre las calificaciones universitarias tradicionales.
Estoy harto de ellas.
Las calificaciones nos obsesionan,
porque nos obsesionan los datos.
Las calificaciones le quitan la diversión al fracaso,
y la educación en gran medida
consiste en fracasar.
El valor, según Churchill,
es la capacidad de ir de un fracaso a otro
sin perder el entusiasmo. (Risas)
Y [Joyce] dijo que los errores
son los portales del descubrimiento.
Y, sin embargo, no toleramos los errores
y adoramos las calificaciones.
Juntamos los regulares y los buenos
y los consolidamos en un número como 3,4
que está estampado en tu frente
y resume lo que eres.
Bueno, en mi opinión, fuimos demasiado lejos con esta tontería
y la calificación se tornó "des-calificación".
Con eso, me gustaría decir unas palabras sobre la actualización,
y compartir con Uds. una idea de mi proyecto actual,
que es diferente del anterior,
pero comparte las mismas características
de aprender haciéndolo uno mismo,
de la exploración personal y el desarrollo comunitario
y abarca la educación inicial y primaria en matemáticas.
Empieza con matemáticas a temprana edad
y con tabletas porque creemos que la matemática,
como todo, debe enseñarse con las manos en la masa.
Por eso, en esencia, desarrollamos
muchas aplicaciones móviles, cada una dedicada
a un concepto matemático particular.
Por ejemplo, tomemos "área".
Cuando uno trabaja un concepto como área...
bueno, siempre brindamos unas herramientas que invitan al chico
a experimentar para aprender.
Así, si lo que nos interesa es el área, lo
que resulta natural es dividirla
en piezas con esta forma y simplemente contar
cuántas piezas se requieren para cubrir el área.
Y este pequeño ejercicio da una buena idea preliminar
del concepto de área.
Continuando, ¿qué pasa con el área de esta figura?
Bueno, si tratamos de cuadricularla eso no funciona bien, ¿no?
En cambio, podemos experimentar
con estas herramientas, siguiendo una guía,
por ensayo y error,
hasta que en un momento descubriremos que,
entre las varias transformaciones legítimas,
existe una en la que si cortamos la figura
podemos reagrupar las partes, pegarlas,
y luego cuadricular el área como hicimos antes.
(Aplausos)
Pero esta transformación particular
no cambió el área de la figura original así que
niñas y niños de 6 años que juegan con esto
han descubierto un algoritmo ingenioso
para calcular el área de cualquier paralelogramo.
No reemplazamos a los maestros, por cierto.
Creemos en facultar a los maestros, no en reemplazarlos.
Siguiendo, ¿qué pasa con el área del triángulo?
Luego de un ensayo y error dirigido
se descubre, con o sin ayuda,
que se puede duplicar la figura original
para luego transponerla,
pegarla a la figura original y después proceder como hicimos antes:
cortamos, reagrupamos, pegamos — uy— pegamos
y cuadriculamos.
Pero esta transformación ha duplicado el área
de la figura original, y por lo tanto acabamos de aprender
que el área del triángulo equivale al área de este rectángulo
dividido por dos.
Lo descubrimos mediante autoexploración.
Así, además de aprender algo útil de geometría
se aprenden estrategias científicas bastante sofisticadas
como la reducción
que es el arte
de transformar un problema complejo en uno simple,
o la generalización que es el centro
de cualquier disciplina científica,
o el hecho de que algunas propiedades son invariables
bajo ciertas transformaciones.
Y todo esto es algo que los pequeños pueden
aprender con sus aplicaciones móviles.
Actualmente, hacemos lo siguiente.
Primero, descomponemos el plan de estudios de matemática inicial y primaria
en muchas de estas aplicaciones.
Y, como no podemos hacerlo por nuestra cuenta,
hemos desarrollado una herramienta muy elegante
que cualquier autor, padre o, de hecho cualquier persona
interesada en enseñar matemática,
puede usar esta herramienta para desarrollar aplicaciones similares
en tabletas, sin programación.
Y, por último, estamos armando un ecosistema adaptativo
que se ajustará a diferentes alumnos
con aplicaciones diferentes de acuerdo a su evolución en el aprendizaje.
La fuerza subyacente que impulsa este proyecto
es mi colega Shmulik London,
y, ya ven, igual que hizo
Salman hace unos 90 años,
el truco es rodearse de personas brillantes,
porque al final,
en todo están las personas.
Hace unos años caminaba por Tel Aviv,
vi este graffiti en una pared
y me pareció tan convincente
que ahora lo predico a mis estudiantes,
y me gustaría hacerlo con Uds.
No sé cuántos de los aquí presentes están familiarizados
con el término "Mensch".
Básicamente significa "ser humano"
y hacer lo correcto.
Dicho esto, este graffiti dice:
"Alta tecnología, tecnología 'schmigh'.
Lo más importante es ser un 'Mensch'". (Risas)
Gracias. (Aplausos)
(Aplausos)